[Música]
la unión europea me retiró de su lista
de paraísos fiscales a las islas
seychelles anguila y dominica lo que ha
generado críticas tras las revelaciones
de los papeles de pandora que expusieron
los secretos financieros de cerca de 35
jefes de estado y también de gobierno
varios de ellos ya respondieron ya sea
negando lo o asegurando que harán sus
propias investigaciones el rey por
ejemplo abdullah de jordania negó que
tenga compañías offshore para poder así
esconder sus lujosas propiedades también
lo hicieron el primer ministro de
pakistán y el kremlin quien negó que las
acusaciones de que el presidente
vladimir putin le comprara una lujosa
propiedad de mónaco a una mujer con la
que tenía una relación sean ciertas
también los líderes de américa latina'
desmintieron estos señalamientos y la
lista pues por supuesto se extiende por
ello quiero saludar a nuestro primer
invitado del día amén sobre este tema
los o pandora paper se les ha mario
alejandro valencia economista y magíster
en políticas públicas analistas a la red
de justicia tributaria una iniciativa
académica y social para hacer
seguimiento a estos temas tributarios
que afectan a toda la población gracias
mario por estar aquí con nosotros en
directo américa de france 24 hablemos
del tema del día del tema que va a estar
pues en la semana por supuesto evasión
fiscal papeles de pandora cómo funciona
este también le quiero preguntar si
todas las personas que tienen una
propiedad una una empresa offshore pues
incurren en el blanqueo de capitales
acción fiscal
buenos días gracias por invitarme no no
todas las personas que tienen una
empresa o tienen una cuenta en el
extranjero digamos son susceptibles de
ser personas acusadas de evasión o de
lavado de dinero pero si generan muchas
sospechas porque cuando una persona o
una empresa se radica en uno de esos
territorios sabe exactamente que se está
encontrando allí lo hace de manera
deliberada y sabe por qué lo está
haciendo lo hace fundamentalmente por
tres razones
los por razones de secreto porque estos
territorios mantienen un secreto muy
alto sobre los nombres de las empresas y
las actividades de las empresas sobre
las operaciones que realizan las
empresas en estos territorios y
fundamentalmente sobre los dueños reales
sobre las personas que son los dueños
reales de estas compañías así que pues
genera sospecha porque se conoce a sus
territorios como guaridas financieras y
justamente lo hacen es para refugiarse
para esconderse ahora le quiero
preguntar cuáles son los territorios más
comunes donde la gente pues abre este
tipo de empresas para ya lo que dijo
usted cómo esconderse o evitar cualquier
tipo pues de lo que quieran evitar no
depende de la persona que abra su
offshore
pero los territorios más conocidos son
estos antiguos territorios de las islas
británicas en el caribe pero casualmente
digamos también hay otros territorios
que no son tan con los videos bueno esta
suiza que tiene un alto secreto
financiero está panamá al caso
latinoamericano es el mayor territorio
en américa latina en donde se refugian
en donde se crean este tipo de empresas
sólo seremos dignos del caso de hace
cinco años de los panamá papers de una
compañía muy famosa que hacía esto que
es moza fonseca pero también aparece
eeuu y aquí hay un estado en eeuu que es
el estado de delaware que es conocido
mundialmente por ser incluso en algunos
indicadores en algunos escalafones el
segundo territorio en el mundo de mayor
opacidad financiera que existe también
le quería preguntar mário cuál es esa
diferencia ya que usted luego lo sacó a
colación los panamá papers de los o
pandora paper o su cuál es la diferencia
estas investigaciones en que se
diferencian
bueno realmente la diferencia es el
tamaño de la información y en la
capacidad de análisis de la información
panamá paper fueron quizás los primeras
la primera filtración de gran tamaño de
este tipo de compañías y eso digamos que
llegó a algunos países por ejemplo
españa ha sido muy acucioso en
investigar y en hacerles seguimiento
para qué pasó con esas empresas y esas
personas que se encontraron aquí
conocemos algunos casos famosos de
grandes deportistas grandes artistas que
han sido acusados de evasión de
impuestos y que han terminado pagando
por esos impuestos que no que no habían
declarado
y está
pues estábamos hablando con mario
alejandro valencia vamos a ver si pues
ya vamos a recuperar ya tenemos la
comunicación mario te perdimos o por un
segundo pero ya puedes continuar
hablando que ya te tenemos después
nítido gracias tenía decía que esta
revelación lo que permite es que haya
más un número de empresas y de personas
y que se tenga ya se haya tenido más
tiempo de investigar realmente qué es lo
que hay allí insisto en este punto no
significa que estar en un territorio de
éstos genere inmediatamente una evasión
de impuestos pero sí es muy sospechoso
por ejemplo en el caso de américa latina
que funcionarios públicos personas que
manejan administran recursos públicos
aparezcan allí y quizás eso lo que en lo
más lamentable lo más flotante que se
puede mostrar en esto de pandora paper
si es que presidentes y ministros y
funcionarios de diversos niveles
congresistas aparecen en esta lista
incluso en el caso colombiano quien es
la persona
encargada
y administrar los tributos del país
aparece allí en esa lista gritos y nos
permite tener más información ya tenemos
digamos más experiencia poder analizar
esa información -mario cuanto se deja de
pagar en impuestos por esconder este
dinero en los llamados paraísos fiscales
las estimaciones que se han hecho a
nivel global te dan unos unos resultados
aproximados de alrededor de 280 mil
millones de dólares para ponerlo en
perspectiva esto es igual al producto
interno bruto de chile y es el doble de
lo que se destina en el mundo lo que se
conoce como la ayuda oficial al
desarrollo